let's jump into this next story we have
from NBC people I see people are super
chatting about this U.S Marshals service
suffers major security breach that
compromises sensitive information senior
law enforcement officials say the
incident did not involve the database
involving witness security program blah
blah blah but they're going to say
sensitive information the effective
system contains law enforcement
sensitive info including returns from
legal process administrative information
personally identifiable information
pertaining to sub subjects of usms
Investigations third parties and certain
U.S Ms employees Wades at the incident
occurred February 17th when the marshals
service discovered a ransomware and data
exfiltration event affecting a
standalone usms system it's got me
thinking
in the event of war with China you know
what I think they're going to do
I think they're going to release
everybody's private info you think China
will use it I mean maybe China somebody
one of the most powerful cyber attacks
you can do is not a nuclear one of the
most powerful acts of War would not be a
surveillance balloon or even a bomb it
would be taking everybody's data and
Publishing it yeah yeah people would you
know we've talked about this before
a lot of people said that when the
Soviet Union fell and like everyone's
secret files got released everyone just
agreed to shut up and not bring it up
because everybody had bad stuff in there
yeah but yo it's gonna get crazy when
like you know some leftist teachers DMS
get released and they're saying a whole
bunch of racial slurs it's gonna dish
like it's gonna be nuts so I I was I was
seeing the story and I'm just thinking
about to what extent are some of these
cyber attacks acts of War think about it
for inter okay so maybe it's
embarrassing if someone publishes your
web browser history or something right
but what if a foreign Nation publishes a
a all the criminal court proceedings and
all the communications from
investigators just completely disrupting
our legal system especially if they
weave in uh falsehoods Within These huge
dumps of of truths and then they could
pick like specific little things where
like a piece of data is is slightly
skewed to make something look make
someone look guilty or someone not look
guilty I find myself imagining when you
get those calls it's like we want to
call you by your extended warranty like
what if they stole everyone's data they
leak it and then you just bombard every
communication system so there's no way
to get actual information class and it
sounds a little bit ridiculous but if
you made it so that no one wanted to
pick up their phone no one wanted to you
know check their email no one wanted to
communicate with you at all they
couldn't trust that their identity
hadn't been stolen I mean it would be
chaos but it's not about your identity
being stolen those phone calls can serve
two purposes the first is my phone rings
I think I got like seven scam calls
today it's like scam likely just endless
and then I get voicemails that are just
in Mandarin I can't do anything with
that all it does is waste my time but
you have to think about it this way you
ever see a movie Office Space yeah and
they're like we were a program that
takes fractions of a fraction of a penny
from these transactions over a long
period of time we'll make a bunch of
money
China's probably looking at it in a
similar way in terms of War I'm not
saying these phone calls are coming from
the Chinese government maybe but think
about it this way if a phone call
disrupts an individual worker in the
United States by .0001 of their daily
productivity that's me it means nothing
to the individual but as a collective
the entirety of the United States that
could be seriously damaging it could it
could you know stack up to the point
where all of that it's like strapping a
weight to the ankle of the American
economy they are slowing us down the
other thing is if people actually answer
the phone and it's calling about your
extended warranty and they give in to
these scams and give money away now
they're actually stealing resources they
can then use in their war effort
yeah yeah you shoot a 400 000 missile at
a balloon and you wasted four hundred
thousand dollars but if you spend
because it wasn't way more than that it
was well it was per missile I think they
shot two so it was total but uh well all
right but yeah you spend 100 Grand on
missiles or you spend 800 grand
um putting together some you know
algorithm and and you what's your costs
the data basically that's your only cost
and it can just run in the background
when the US says whatever you want when
the US has the internet knocked out we
all go oh geez the internet's out but
how much economic activity is disrupted
by that yeah slowing U.S growth and
allowing and then China carries on as
you know nothing happens it's happened
in Canada last year there was a big
internet outage one of the
telecommunication companies went down
and I mean it was it was not just
workers but also bus systems because all
of the bus passes are hooked up to the
Internet so you can't get anywhere I
mean it went on for like two the outage
was I think 24 maybe over that and uh
the the chaos that ensued it took a long
time it took several weeks to recover
from because the city was just not
prepared to lose the internet and with
China stealing releasing data it in
particular it's challenging to think
about because you just don't know how
much data has been released and
collected by China I mean I know we saw
all it was like 26 States now have
specifically banned tick tock on
government-issue devices and government
networks because part of tick tock's uh
policies is that it collects not just
information on your phone but also your
browsing history and on your keystrokes
and all of these things like if you had
that but you were a government worker
and so you were on the DMV Wi-Fi and so
you have all of this information and
you've been looking up different things
for people like that's a lot of very
sensitive data that's just sitting in
this app's purview China if you're
listening name your price for Eric
swalwell's browser history
I think Fong Fong was watching you know
like she probably got it they were
probably working on that together plus
like if someone's got I think kind of
along the lines what you're saying if
someone's got tick tock on their phone
and then they got my name and number and
email address and their phone as a
contact now the CCP has my my email
address well I'm doing something
Facebook's already been doing I mean
Facebook collects your brows your like
if you have a Facebook Messenger open it
can read all your other tabs on your
computer so there's no way to put it
back in the Box wait Facebook Messenger
can read all the tabs on your browser
it's either Facebook or Facebook
Messenger in their terms of service they
can like if you have it open they can
read the other stuff that's going on
they can like collect the data I don't
know about on a computer how that would
work on a on a phone I would understand
it's on any internet browser I mean I'm
not an expert but this is something that
I had been told I know that websites all
have the Facebook tracker so Facebook
knows where you are all the time the
scary thing about Facebook is the shadow
profiles you guys know about that yeah
they build that based on the contacts in
your phone exactly all that other data
all the data they collect from
everywhere builds a pro profile on you
whether you want it or not yeah isn't it
really funny was it the CIA working on
some program
you know about tracking the life of
every single person and then they cancel
the program and then Facebook launched
they're on the same time really like the
same time
yeah what was that called I think the
people in the chat will know that the
CIA or something was working on some
some program called like life track or
something like that and they wanted to
create profiles on everybody and then
all of a sudden they just canceled the
program
then Facebook starts it's like somebody
probably went to the boss and said why
are we going to do all this work
tracking people and we can just convince
them and do it for us yeah they'll beg
us to post their photos and share do you
feel like we're on the defensive you
know they're saying lifelong
and I say life Vlog is that what it was
called that's kind of crazy
your security guy do you feel like we're
on the defensive with this like DARPA
lifelong reacting to someone collecting
our data as opposed to actively securing
it yeah I I think
you know part of that's a product of
when you got into the into the tech age
I mean I'm 37 so I had a phone when I
was 12 but I like wasn't allowed to use
it unless it was an emergency and you
know phone plans at that time had 500
texts a month and so it was just a
different age
um but like this is I'm I'm kind of like
a Bitcoin guy and so there's a lot
there's a whole segment of uh the the
Bitcoin industry that's uh really into
the security side of it and
so
it just depends on how you started right
like people once you once you start
going down a path you're unlikely to
shift so people who have started using
technology uh before thinking about
security as being something that they
should think about are probably unlikely
or in some cases not even it's not even
really possible for them to go all the
way back to square one and build
security from the ground up like if if
you're if you're doing 10 things that
are unsecure and then you decide well
I'm going to start taking security
seriously well it's probably already too
late unless you're going to get a new
phone number you're going to completely
get rid of anything that you used prior
and you're and you're going to start
from scratch
um so I think your average person is
just very unlikely to do that so you
have to think about where does it make
the most sense like so for me when I got
into Bitcoin
um you know I was kind of uh of a
neophyte in it at the very beginning I
was just paying attention to what was
popular in the media uh and then I
actually went to a Bitcoin a conference
called guns in Bitcoin last year and
started talking I mean like I was the
dumbest guy in the room honestly these
guys were some of the smartest people
I've I've ever been around but it was
funny how much we had in common with
them uh which was kind of the point of
the conference it was a lot about 3D
printing guns and Bitcoin and you know
self-sovereignty and um two different
groups looking at the same problem from
a different perspective and so
um thinking about okay well if you're
gonna have your own Bitcoin like well
are you really in control of it you know
do you know your keys are you connected
to your own node do you have a secure
wallet like you know you so in that case
yeah like I'm pretty confident that I've
done the right things in that one area
of my life but are there a bunch of
other ways that I'm I'm probably
deficient from a security perspective
yeah well the majority of people like
you're saying just never think about it
I mean like in the gun Community a big
thing has been like we know that uh the
we know that Facebook and
um Instagram and the tech companies are
developing ways to pull the serial
number off of photos of guns so if you
take a photo of a gun and they can see
the serial number they are digitizing
that just like you do you you know
character recognition uh OCR and so
that's a big thing that was a big thing
for a while you got you can't show your
serial number on the internet because
then they'll know that it's yours and
then they're are going to build this
Shadow registry that supposedly they're
not allowed to do but we all know that
they are so like in my case I mean
there's so many pictures of my guns out
on the internet like what can I do at
that point now going forward I could
make sure that I don't do that with
anything that I don't want them to know
that I have yeah but once you've once
you've let that cat out of the bag it's
pretty hard to put it back in thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time